hello and welcome to playstation grenade
spider-man mars morales follows in the
footsteps of the sublime 2018 game and
hits us with
19 more suits and a ton of mods to
unlock too
in this video we're going to go through
all of them and decide which suit
is the greatest and i challenge you to
list your top five suits in the comments
it's harder than it looks
[Music]
so at number 19 we have the star to suit
mouse wares
it's a cross between a legit spider-man
suit and well
warmth the game is set at christmas in
the snowy period so i understand why
miles has done this
basketball shots with under armour and
some damn fine trainers
or sneakers if you prefer a cool thing
of note is that this suit and all the
others
will degrade over time with rips and
dirt depending on the mission
which is impressive to see it's dynamic
next let's keep things going with
another
beginner suit check out miles and his
spider training suit
this is interesting for a few reasons
firstly this is the very last suit
you'll likely unlock in the game
as it's only available once you start
new game plus
the thing that makes this one special is
that it's actually always been here
those who played the dlc from spider-man
2018
will recognize this as the clothing
miles war during his first training
sessions with peter
in the city that never sleeps dlc it's
also just like peter's ecu
suit which reps his school for miles
that's brooklyn visions academy
more on that soon though this suit has a
hidden suit mod
power transfer which lets miles convert
camouflage energy
into venom power so when you're not
being sneaky
convert invisibility into bioelectricity
at number 17 here's the great
responsibility suit
miles first official suit made just for
him and not one of peter's cast offs
although judging by the fit especially
around the neck this is likely one of
peter's cast offs
the coolest thing about this suit is the
elbow and knee pads to show
miles is not fully ready to take the
training wheels off just yet
peter's still looking out for him he
still rocks his adidas shoes
which i'm told is pronounced adidas in
the us which sounds way more epic than
adidas
anyway there's no mod attached to this
suit so let's crack on
next we have the classic mild suit it's
a damn gorgeous design i'm sure you
agree
and it's the way we all picture miles
the signature red crashing through the
midnight black
we call it the classic suit for a reason
this suit comes with another suit
modification
you know when spider-man rips a weapon
out of the enemy's hands and then hits
them with it while the mod here lets
miles create a concussive force
when that weapon shatters in a fight
frustratingly though
this only works on underground weapons
you know those purple guys
so this mod isn't as great as it could
be but still very useful
yes indeed we are now up to number 15
and it's exactly the same suit
but with a key difference it's now much
warmer and keeps spider-man toasty
inside
this is the winter suit the scarf flaps
around in the wind and during maskless
cutscenes
the earmuffs drop around his neck it's
the small touches okay
this suit does not have a superpower nor
does it look badass but for comedy value
in cutscenes
it's totally worth it he's like santa's
little helper
next on the list okay it's the same suit
again can you see why i'm putting these
all together
this time the classic suit is juxtaposed
with the brooklyn vision uniform
the blazer and backpack set this one off
but like other suits
his shoes are here again and his
wireless headphones too which look to be
based on beats
there's a reason why this is higher in
the list than the other classic
iterations
check out the visor mod whilst cruising
around and trying not to swing face
first into a building
miles can perform tricks by holding
square and going crazy with the left
thumb stick
with the trick master mod it's possible
to turn these random stunts
into pure venom power the more twirly
whirly means more bioelectricity
and bioelectrically wins fight let's
crack on
and the next suit is the strike suit
just look at this beautiful monstrosity
it's like spawn meets the future this
suit brings spiders to miles
gauntlets and it looks really good at
night because of the glowing effect
i have one issue with the suit and
that's that the spider on his chest
looks more like a tie to me like he's
going on a superhero interview
maybe i'm hung up on that for the wrong
reasons but the suit is pure fire
without that part
the visor mod installed is venom
overclock which means once your venom
meter is full it will actually heal
miles over time like small health
droplets
pretty useful we're up to number 12 on
the list and it's time for the homemade
suit
if you read the comics you'll be more
impressed with this one than many people
this is indeed miles first attempt at
making his own spider suit
it's very functional he looks like he's
going skiing in that mask
but he keeps his identity safe and to
keep things
extra functional check out the footwear
i reckon they are steel toe cap too
but i have no proof this suit has a mod
power pitcher which takes spider-man's
ability to throw things to the next
level
increasing damage of objects and making
knockouts far more likely
onto the track suit the most overstated
suit in the game
the white and black making it impossible
for spider-man to hide
just like in the 2018 game this is a
brand new design
specifically made for the game and has
the same confidence as peter's
i know this is weird but check out those
toes
like ninja feet how cool is that okay i
know that's weird that i'm checking out
people's feet
my butt the visor mod here can be useful
if you're hit by snipers regularly
it decreases damage from ranged attacks
by 25
but come on dude those toes wow hey
we've made it to the top ten things get
spicy from here on in but it's a suit
you've seen before
which is kicking off this top ten the
animated suit
straight from the animated tv show this
miles has the oversized eye design
and just check out that cel-shaded
goodness it's super weird to see this
layered on top of photorealistic
graphics
but it's undeniably good this suit also
has a mod which makes miles's webs
stronger this means when miles binds an
enemy in battle
they will take far longer to break free
thus making them unable to fight when
things get hectic
next we have the crimson cowl suit and
i'm sure you know where the name comes
from
it has a red hood but that name is taken
so we call it a crimson cowl instead if
anybody asks
in terms of design this is the cleanest
suit in the game
minimal design with minimal excess
layers only the hood is really defined
here
i did a little research and found the
name crimson cowl is used numerous
times in marvel history from ultron to
justine hammer
it's likely the latter is the nod here
this suit has a great mod to unlock
it's a visor mod named ghost strike and
is arguably the best mod in the game
depending on how you play you'll likely
use the web strike takedown
but if someone is near it will be heard
or seen and causes a ruckus
ghost strike makes it so enemies can't
hear the takedown
as long as miles is camouflaged this is
legitimately fantastic and makes getting
rid of big bad guys in a fight
far easier i really recommend it at
number eight on the list
is the bodega catsuit no you ain't seen
things the previews didn't lie
there is a variant of the classic suit
with a cat named spider-man
wearing a spider-man mask on the back of
spider-man
i said spider-man a lot there this suit
is earned via a side quest called cat's
pajamas
and is part of this graffitied hoodie
look which again keeps those adidas
shoes
sadly this suit does not have a
modification
but don't worry because it holds a
secret instead randomly during takedowns
spider-man will assist spider-man check
it out it doesn't get old either
if you need some spider-man on
spider-man action you've come to the
right place
i need to get out more moving on next we
have the brilliant miles morales 2099
suit
the awesome red white and blue evil
looking spider on his chest
set off against that crushing black and
check out those eyes too
the heat and mist coming from then looks
impressive
this suit is just like the title
suggests a nod to the 2099 version of
spider-man who is miguel o'hara in that
world
if you don't know too much about it
don't worry neither do i
but if you watch the end of into the
spider verse you'll already have seen
him
good old post credit scenes come to the
rescue our miles has all the future tech
here but still keeps his signature hood
there is an ability with this one too a
suit mod with venom suppression
resistance
this sounds more epic than it actually
is this will shorten the time miles
can't use his powers when rocks on
troops hit him aggressively hard
cool note is that by activating your
camouflage it'll instantly remove energy
transfers
which is damn useful when things go all
kind of wrong in the late game
at number six say hello to the purple
rain suit
this suit is another which is completely
different from the rest with a vibrant
shiny green offset against this matte
purple
the eyes here are way more reduced and
seemingly quite sinister
miles has a utility belt but it's the
hands we need to focus on
panther like claws which look like he's
prowling into action
if you know the colour scheme here
you've likely figured out how miles gets
this in the game
but let's not say it out loud to save
spoilers for people the purple range
suit has a visor mod named reclaimer
this one replenishes one gadget worth of
ammo
after performing a melee stealth
takedown to any enemy
a guaranteed way to stack gadgets if
that's the way you play
into the top five we go next we have the
sublime uptown pride suit
just look at how striking it is if
you're wondering why it isn't higher
it's due to this being a basic color
swap of the original suit
and also it has no mod attached which is
a real shame
but if you're thinking this should be
lower then let me tell you about this
suit
the uptown pride suit is unlocked by
completing the side quest through the
app that miles has
each one of those people you help is a
member of the public in your
neighborhood
these people then club together to make
this suit as a sign of respect
for their spider-man truly brilliant
it's found under a black lives matter
mural which really hits home the
importance here
please don't be that guy who writes
white lives matter in the comments
we've known that forever sadly some
people need reminding that other lives
matter too anyway for additional detail
check out the golden sections
they're actually individual triangles
with shimmer damn this suit is great
next take a look-see at miles morales
2020 suit
it's like daft punk had a spider baby
this design has been seen in the comics
and takes the work of dan slott and his
2020 series approach
visually it's futuristic and retro at
the same time
it's got these 80s shoulder padding and
shoes straight out of back to the future
it screams as if someone in the past was
trying to predict the future
the neon mask and chest plate really
make this pop and then there's the logo
on the back
which is stuck in the 1990s and to say
this is a future suit
why is he using wired headphones dude
this is 20 20.
the jacket bellows in the wind and his
eye neon shapes change when speaking
overall a great suit but there's no more
to add to this brilliance
rip okay top three times someone is
going to get upset
here's the end suit looking at this suit
it's easy to think i've gone insane
placing this in the top three
but hear me out the end suit is in fact
from the end series of comic books
which takes a look at the way a
superhero dies
their final mission where they usually
make the ultimate sacrifice
this means this is the last suit miles
will wear when he dies
and to me that hits hard in the comic
book version miles is an old man by the
time he wears this stuff with gray hair
of course in game now his face and voice
don't change he remains
young miles this suit demonstrates miles
his entire life
and look at him after all the years he
still wears a hoodie
on the reverse it's still the graffitied
spider once again
showing he's aged but still the same guy
and there are weird choices too
like military fatigues in digital camo
no less
and the footwear has evolved to be
stylish but more boot-like
i like this design and there is also a
suit mod named steady focus
this is a stealth mod which slows down
how quickly miles can remain
undetected in transparent camouflage and
should you stand still
the camo drops even slower pretty
impressive
next we have second place the
programmable mata suit
who'd have thought we'd be impressed
with a suit that looks like it was made
on the ps1
but those polygons really work the jet
black is metallic this time and shines a
thousand different ways
with each step the feet and hands glow
red and then disperse back into the
black gradually
personally this really is my favorite
spider design on his chest
and the bigger version on the back we
also must take a moment to pay respects
to miles
and his polygonal badonkadonk insert
witty joke here
anyway sadly there is no suit mod here i
was devastated because this was easily
my favorite suit in the game
but there is something secret a secret
takedown move hidden away
check this out the iron spider takedown
makes a return
the low poly look continues onto the
legs and it's simply brilliant
if this had a suit mod i'm sure this
would be top of the pile
but second is pretty good what about you
where would you put this one
and now we have our winner
[Music]
the into the spider-verse suit okay i'll
be honest the movie is easily my
favorite in the spider-man lineage
so i know i have a little prejudice here
but let's break this brilliance down
firstly like the animated suit this
costume pops on photorealistic streets
but also look at the proportions of
miles his hands are bigger his stance is
longer his torso is shorter
they all follow the visuals of the movie
the graffiti spider returns as do the
oversized animated eyes
but the two greatest things about this
suit are modifications
in the text it says vibe the verse use
this mod to leap into the spider-verse
and cause the attached suit to mimic the
aesthetic of a different world
we've likely seen this first mod the
suit animates in a stuttering fashion to
mimic that of the movie
miles moves on the second frame each
time so it feels a bit delayed
but there's a second mod here check this
out perfect sight
a mod which brings the onomatopoeia
sounds into text form
just like in comic books legend has it
that if you do this enough you'll one
day see the sacred
bagel visual effect from the movie i
haven't seen it yet but i think that
myth
is definitely worth sharing so to me the
best suit
and mods in the game is the into the
spiderverse suit
pure perfection of course keep in mind
we can use any of these mods on any suit
making our very own personal miles
morales
so now's the time tell me your thoughts
and shout at me for being wrong in the
comments
please tell me your top five in those
comments and maybe i'll make a follow-up
video
listing your favorites which is the best
mars morales suit
over to you guys i'm adam from
playstation grenade if you got this far
into the video thank you very much for
your time
i really appreciate it i'll uh see you
next time
[Music]